[Music]
welcome back
fun fact our next guest almost took over
the role of steve in blue's clues i
didn't even know that please welcome
justin long
no
[Applause]
we haven't seen each other we we've been
texting and and and audio messages yes
we're just reuniting on national
television like you do yeah you know how
when
your former love has a host a show and
yeah this is wild um okay so i was
talking with mike berbiglia the amazing
comedian very funny yes um and i
compliment you
and i heard you heard about it because
it went everywhere well it was the most
flat it was for you to be saying how
funny i am now first of all i feel like
i have to be really funny to live up to
that
you're so funny i know what do you got
what do you got uh that's it that's what
he said he said it but it it was so
flattering i mean you know i think of
you and i wanted to say i said it as i
was watching it you're the funny one i
mean you are
one of the funniest people i've ever met
everyone who knows this because they
watch your show you know that it's you
go toe-to-toe when you're a kid with
letterman not many people can do that
you're the you're yeah we had a lot of
laughs we that's what we did we laughed
we left all the time so much yeah like
that was so much a part of our
connection was that we love funny people
yeah we enjoy laughing at all times i
love that we've maintained our love
because it i i don't think it'll ever i
know from my end it'll never go anywhere
i'll love you always you know and so i i
i'm glad that we're able to
still have that i mean that i i always
love you
i i will always love you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
oh i feel like we've been through so
much together too you know i feel like
when we used to like talk and facetime i
was always like you know i've really
grown up justin like i always wanted to
prove
to you what a different person i was
than when we dated you were the best we
had so much fun no i know it was it too
but we were you know
more hedonistic a little more immature
you know we would get together we would
break up you know there was chaos it was
hell of fun fun chaos oh yeah yeah well
it's yeah most hedonism is fun there's
not a lot of bad hedonism
i don't think if you look yes for
hedonism
yeah
[Applause]
[Laughter]
yeah you're doing it wrong then we had a
blast and i cherish that time i do i i
mean when we first met you were such a
bachelor that you
you had like a i was funny
when we first met you know i was 20 21
yeah oh my god i was 20. you barely
leave wow hey you like him like him yeah
i like the older ladies
[ __ ] it up under hedonism you had um an
overstuffed trash compactor
and um holes in your sheet in an outdoor
gym i'm just gonna say
oh my god we're game nights yes oh god
it was a nut case i used to like just
drink and be like
[Applause]
i was that guy like i wasn't true it was
wild i was i remember playing with
quentin tarantino oh my god we played
with quentin yeah and he was going and
he was what it is and he was all juiced
up and wild and
yes
i i
i live for that by the way
i that is the greatest compliment to get
a genuine drew spit take fast you still
have it in there sorry finally
but
if you know quentin tarantino
everything is like on 20. yes yeah the
stakes are so high and it's like it's a
game you know we would get uh we had the
best yeah game nights game nights were
fun yeah you know
one of the things i find so compelling
and what i said at the beginning of the
show in the cold open is
you know how great it is to champion
your ex
because i wonder where does the
friendship go and if we can
be that and and and people can have that
it's so um
respecting
of what once was
yes that it shouldn't just
yeah yes yeah
can i applause for that can i yeah yeah
yeah
it's true it's true well said yeah um
although i did want to kill you last
night uh i watched your film barbarian
well thank you for watching again i
guess oh no and no thank you okay um
it taps into like multiple layers of
fears
and we actually have a clip um will you
please roll it don't look
i like to let my baby determine how long
he likes to nurse
oh god
[Music]
um
now
i just want to brag for a moment now
this movie has a currently and rising 94
percent on rotten tomatoes 94
uh this is
that's so sweet this is zach cragar you
would love him zach wrote and directed
it zach is is uh such a funny warm
person but obviously very dark somewhere
in there well pleasure to be here i
could not be happier for you it's like
all i want in life is your success and
your happiness
likewise
and i'm so happy
that you are in this also amazing
relationship and it's you know it makes
it just so
i'm just so happy because you deserve to
be happy i'm so thrilled she does all
those things she is and and she adores
you and she is the most
supportive most wonderful it's funny you
want to know we gotta you would love
hanging out we'll all go out yes
[Applause]
you're so good at this by the way you're
doing it so well thank you
so relieved
all right after the break justin and i
answer some audience questions about us
[Music]
you